yeah yeah yeah i cried when i left harper on the break here the first day yeah i'm in kindergarten i'm putting tears all the time it's like bittersweet right i know they spread their wings and swine yeah you had a nice day for it it was great oh everything's going perfect oh my god the night before that they had proms and And everybody went to Billy Park in Nashville.
I don't know if they don't park.
It's a nice little bit of a park.
They're all in their gowns.
And every time I see my little brand.
Came a long way with Johnny Sacks.
Hola.
I would like to start the committee of conference on HB 315.
And I welcome everybody who's watching the bio live stream.
And I welcome Senator Abarth and Senator Waters from the Senate side, and Representative Thomas, Representative Harrington, and Representative Jim Kelly Pitts from the House side.
This morning, we had a Committee of conference on Senate Bill 91.
That committee of conference recessed after about a half an hour, because there are some questions that need to be studied.
The outcome of that committee of conference weighs upon this committee of conference.
Therefore, I'm going to call a recess of this committee of conference until tomorrow at 10 a.m.
in rooms 201 and 203 of the legislative office building.
All right.
Without objection.
You give directions yeah without objection this meeting is precepted thank you for coming thank you glad we had this talk and we did feel very well Thank you.
Thank you.
To the Committee of Conference on HB 542.
My name is Representative McLean and I'll be chairing the Committee Conference.
And so things are a little bit less formal.
We're not taking minutes and we're not taking the role, but what we will do, especially for those who may be watching remotely in the audience, I just go around the table and just ask everybody to introduce themselves and, you know, who they represent.
represent.
I'll start with myself, Mark McLean, representing Hillsborough District 44, which is Southern Manchester and the town of Litchfield.
And I'm Representative Kurt Welker, I represent Stratford District 3, which is the towns of Stratford and New York.
I'm Representative Joe Alexander, I represent Hillsborough District 6, the town of Gostown.
Mike Sylvia, Representative from Belmont, Belmont District 6.
And I'm Senator Becky Whitley.
I represent District 15, which is Concord and I put Connecticut Hopkins in the corner.
All right.
Thank you and welcome everybody.
So, um, HB 542, an act relative to the protection of religious liberty.
So, the bill went over to the Senate, and the Senate did quite a little bit of work to it.
And so, I thought we'd just kind of start off, since, unfortunately, you're the only senator here.
Maybe you could kind of go through some of the changes.
I see you did take out quite a bit of stuff.
Sure.
Maybe of walk us through that and some of the thinking, was it redundancy?
Was it not needed?
But just kind of some of the thought process as to why some of those things were all.
Yeah.
So the committee heard a lot of testimony, mostly about the first portion of the bill and heard that most notably from the attorney general's office that the broad definitions in the bill might have some unintended unintended consequences.
So, you know, everyone fully recognized, of course, the importance of free exercise of religion and, you know, the importance of our religious communities, but felt like the language was so broad that it would just have these unintended consequences of having businesses being able to discriminate.
So we had, you know, we have a current anti-discrimination law in New Hampshire, RSA 354A, right?
And this currently exempts houses of worship and religiously affiliated organizations from compliance with the state's inter-discrimination law.
But this bill, the portion that the Senate Judiciary Committee eliminated, the Senate eliminated, would take it further and extend that exemption to all individuals and businesses, regardless of whether they are religious or secular.
So that's the portion that we had concerns with and heard significant testimony, including from the attorney general's office.
That was why the decision from that portion was made.
So that portion, you know, are you speaking about the definition section here where you took out.
A person, for example, the Senate version I just i'm just looking at the side by side, so the Senate version, the definition is removed specifically were person and for state action so.
So specifically, let's just look at the person.
Person means any individual association, partnership, corporation.
So is that the part that they were saying was too broad?
So looking at the bill as amended by the House, basically the full sections full um uh sections one two three were all removed so the remainder of the bill the protection of religious liberty is the one that that remained so those were all so those sections were all primarily uh the finding section so so all the findings were removed So I think, you know, for the most part, we're okay with that.
It's getting into the definitions.
So, and specifically you were saying where we think it's too broad and that it might apply to.
So I'm just looking at the person as it exists in the house version says any individual association partnership corporation church or the institution etc or other legal entity um so that was legal counsel felt that that was too broad correct okay and what was it that they want tied more into an individual or because we we do define person and religious organization so but they left religious organization in there.
And they were okay with that.
Yeah, so I will say that, you know, in when we voted on the entire house, you know, I was in the minority with the voting on the entire bill.
Okay.
You know, I actually think that the definition for religious organization is also incredibly broad because it includes, you know, not just houses of worship, but religious schools and societies and businesses, you know, nearly anyone can claim to be organizing for a religious purpose.
I think we're going to request a break if that's okay so we can wait for our Senate colleagues.
Okay.
Thank you.
Senator Whitley was just went around.
We did some quick introductions.
Senator Whitley kind of went through.
She had discussed the findings had been taken out and she also was up to the point talking about some of the definitions were removed specifically person and state action so she was just kind of going through some of the concerns with the definition of person and some of the consequences that that might bring so not everybody's back maybe we just kind of pick up we're just kind of going through the thing and just because you guys did take quite a bit out.
I'm just trying to understand what were some of the concerns.
OK, some of the initial concerns, the what we were really looking for was a very clear, very concise statement.
And the front of the bill was loaded with purpose statements and we said okay we're not going to deal with this we wanted to make sure that religion and the ability to worship was considered to be an essential service that people needed to go to their church to be allowed to worship as they saw fit, because as we all know during COVID, how awful it was, how people were isolated, and people could receive solace from church, from going to church, listening to their ministers, being able to be with their fellow congregants, how important that was.
And so we wanted to make sure that if we should ever go through anything like this again, religion would be considered essential to the well being of the people in the state of New Hampshire.
So we got rid of all that stuff in the front.
And that's what we concentrated on.
So so and so that so we got to that part.
Some of the definitions, person state action, she was discussing some of the consequences with applying personhood to the state's trusts, foundations, legal entities, all that stuff.
So I'm assuming that was just taken out.
So that would fall back on the common person.
What we hold in common is this is what a person is.
And state action, do you know why that was taken out?
Did you feel that was addressed later on in the bill?
But that definition was taken care of.
What do you mean state action?
Because I'm looking here at as amended by the House.
So the yeah, as amended by the Senate, the definition of state action.
So those two definitions were taken up person and state action.
So page five, side by side.
Oh, I'm looking at the middle.
Okay.
Yes, if you go down, if you guys have a side by side side and you go to page five, and if you look down to Rowland five on the house version, it just defined state action.
It was removed in the Senate version.
So we were just looking to, were you seeing other complications relative to that?
To be quite honest with you, Representative, I believe that we got rid of that particular part because the ability for a person to worship in their church goes well beyond state action.
And the state shouldn't be able to mandate when you're going to be able to go to church and how you're going to be able to church.
That is under the Constitution, under freedom of religion.
So the thinking was then that that definition was right.
Well, there is provision in here that says that state government, it says, shall not enforce any health, safety, or occupancy requirement that imposes a substantial burden on a religious service unless the government demonstrates that the burden to the religious service in this particular instance is essential to further compelling government interests.
So the state, if it had early on deemed religion as being essential and allowing and not even allowing, but they could have imposed the mask mandate or the six feet apart social distancing and ask the churches to do that okay i'm not understanding what what you just said senator because it seems to me that 546 on page 754 16 three state emergency protection roman one has been removed okay i'm looking here Okay, you're're gonna have to point that out to me.
It's on page 16.
Okay, okay, I'm looking at.
Right, that first section is gone, I believe.
So 546 C is also out.
But 546 C is also out.
And so, right.
Okay.
The prohibitions that I see begin on page 7 in the Senate bill with Roman 1 notwithstanding RSA 445.
Right.
When you look at the state of emergency protections that I'm looking at set on page 7, it says shall not prohibit in-person gatherings.
But the senate language says the state government shall permit a religious organization to continue to operate, engage in religious services.
So I think they're the same thing, but they're just coming at it from different ways.
The House version said shall not prohibit.
And this side says shall permit a religious organization.
So I think there's, they accomplished the same thing.
You will follow up?
I will prefer.
Yeah, so I don't think I agree.
And I guess it's two parts.
So in 546, if we're just looking at the emergency protections, right?
Mm-hmm.
The intent of Roman one.
Thank you.
was to assure that in-person gatherings could be held.
And when you say that you can't do it in any greater extent in other organizations or businesses, maybe that's the same thing, but maybe not.
So...
Well, it says shall permit religious organizations to continue to operate.
Yes, and continue to operate.
Shall rather than may.
It says that they're required to allow them to continue.
What we dealt with, Representative, was the term essential.
I think that's one thing we've heard throughout this whole pandemic of COVID was these businesses, these entities, were considered to be essential.
And we argued, in fact, I argued on the floor that my goodness, if Home Depot was considered to be essential, then the ability of a person to go to church and worship as they see fit should also be deemed as essential.
And that our piece here speaks to that.
If there are going to be differentiation between what's going to be open, what's going to be closed, who's going to be allowed to do this and who's going to be allowed to do that, this speaks that the state government shall permit a religious organization to continue operating and to engage in religious services to the same or greater extent that any other organization or business.
So they're not going to be treated any differently.
If all businesses are closed for whatever reason, okay.
But if they're going to start picking and choosing, churches are right up there.
So I suppose that the state in a state of emergency, the state has an emergency order that says there will be no in-person shopping.
And if you want to go to the grocery store or you want to go to any other essential store or liquor stores.
No, liquor stores were considered essential.
I know.
We had that testimony.
If you want to go to the grocery store, you can do that, but you have to do curbside pickup.
By this, that would mean the church could not have people together in their service because gatherings of people was prohibited to everybody else.
I don't think so, Representative.
I don't see that.
What I'm saying is that the order could be issued that would prevent even two people from going into the same place, which would pretty much exclude any religious service, but it wouldn't explicitly do that.
in the in the reading of a neutral way it would but it would it would i representative i don't read it that way um what i read it as saying that a religious organization the church is going to be treated like everyone else, that they are not going to be prohibited from allowing mass or whatever type of religious service that you go to, they're not gonna be able to say you can't do it.
So in the existing state of emergency, the governor alluded to groups of people to attend, if I recall, who couldn't do it by saying it won't be yet?
Well, I, along with Senator Guyton, sat on the Reopen New Hampshire Task Force.
And so Senator Guyton worked very, very closely with a lot of the religious organizations in order for them to open, in order for them to be able to reach out to their congregants.
And what I thought was interesting was that churches had some pretty ingenious ways of reaching out to their followers.
They found a way to make it work.
And so that is what this amendment really our amendment speaks to is that you've got to enable religious organizations to be able to meet.
And it's important that we do so, that they would, they will always be considered to be an essential part of our society and will allow people to meet and to worship as they choose.
So with that in mind, I mean, there may be situations like, let's say you have Ebola times 10, where it's so contagious that five minutes of contact.
So, you know, the next three days, we've got to absolutely shut down and that means nothing.
So that would be a very compelling state interest.
So in that case, moving on just a little bit, C46, if you go to the side by side, the free exercise of religion protected portion, which again goes to the substantial burden.
Yeah, sorry, page six on the left side of the house.
Patrick O' So this gets into kind of detailing out.
Patrick O' essential to furthering a compelling government interest might be a case, for example, where the governor would say no, you can't have any at all that might be Ebola.
times 10 or whatever.
So that kind of preserves, there might be a situation where that's absolutely necessary, and even math aren't going to work.
But that language was taken out as well, which I think might have kind of covered that a little bit.
So was there any thought as to why?
I kind of think that lends something to it, that 546C, colon, 2.
Well, as I said, we just focused on the state of emergency protections.
We felt that that was the really compelling interest here.
It was the real sense of dissatisfaction from so many people across the state that they were not allowed initially to worship in their churches.
And that's what we focused our efforts on.
So why couldn't we just keep one that said any power that's made to proceed to the state of emergency to not permit any person to have it?
If in fact...
Three, one hour or two.
I'm right where it was before.
If in fact, what you said, the way you're interpreting the only one of your bill means that, why is it so important that we don't say it?
Because I think it's inherent in that first section.
So we have two people here who disagree about whether or not it's inherent in that section.
My question is why is it so important that the adults don't say it, right?
In black and white, any power that's ready shall not go in person gatherings and establish houses of worship.
because I think, and I believe it's Representative McClain, am I correct?
Yes.
Brought up the point of Ebola times 10, that there might be a situation where they're just going to say, look, we have to close everything down because this is so, I don't know, the Black Death.
I don't know what you will call it.
Something that is just so contagious.
And for the health, the safety and welfare of the people of the state, we need to do this.
We need to do it for a short period of time.
And hopefully with the work that's being done on 4-17, that's going to get further defined and confined in as far as time, as to how long that can happen.
But I would hope that we would never, ever, ever run into a situation where something like this would happen.
Or what happens if a nuclear bomb was set up, a dirty bomb, or some other sort of extremely catastrophic event where, you know, the governor has to come out and say, listen, we're going to shut everything down.
We have to, but we're going to let churches still go.
I mean, that's where I think that there's a problem.
Again, what we focused on was the fact that early on when decisions were being made about what was considered to be essential, religion and your ability to practice your religion was not considered to be essential.
And the Senate by majority vote disagreed with that.
That we felt that it was important that the ability for people to worship, to go to church, worship however they choose was preserved.
But we also understand that there's hopefully not in my lifetime, not in your lifetime, not in anyone's lifetime, will we ever encounter a situation where everything has to shut down because of some sort of catastrophic event.
So with that in mind, and that's a good point.
So if we were to go back and leave that section then and to go back on to page six, which is the free exercise of religion protected, this is where the kind of making the case for furthering a compelling government interest such as you know Ebola times 10 or something like that.
So what would your thoughts be about putting that section back in, or maybe a part of that section?
I think that section 546 C2 Roman 1, I think is a good clarifying sentence um the uh roman 2 we might want to talk about because there's some other stuff further on when you're talking about qualifying um but i think i think roman one enrollment three may actually provide some some clarity.
Do you have any thoughts on that?
Well, I'd like to look at it a little more closely.
Okay.
Because I want to make this is again this is something that is extremely important, and I want to make sure that we get it right.
Sure.
And that we provide a very clear and concise statement.
So we can consult with the Senate attorney to make sure that that language reflects exactly what we're looking for.
Is there anything else in our version that you...
Well, I think putting one and three and two might be problematic just because I don't understand if you go further on.
You did take out the section on qualified immunity later on.
And so I didn't know how enrollment to in that particular section, maybe interconnected with that later section.
section.
So, but just on that waving of immunity, I guess the concern that some folks had was if you go and you look on the Senate version on page eight, Roman three and Roman four, this is basically laying out what the remedy is.
And so that's basically saying, if there's something that goes against the provisions of this law, this is where it is.
And I think that's good.
The concern some people had was if you look on the House version, where you've eliminated at the bottom of page 8 546 c colon four so the question is um does the elimination of that section take the teeth out of the senate version roman three and roman four no i don't believe so um If you think about immunity waves, who are you actually suing?
Are you going to be suing the governor?
Are you going to be suing the legislature?
Who are you going to be suing?
So I think we need to be very, very careful about that.
I do think that our section here in three and four, Roman 3 and Roman 4, that they can assert a violation of this section as a claim against the state government in any judicial or administrative proceeding, or as a defense in any judicial or administrative proceeding, without regard to whether the proceeding is brought by or in the name of state government, any private person or other party.
I think that that covers it.
It still allows them to bring forward a claim.
We don't have to waive immunity.
And then finally, any religious organization that successfully inserts a claim may recover appropriate relief, including but not limited to.
And it tells you inductive relief, declaratory relief, compensatory compensatory damages costs and attorney fees so i think that that's already addressed so we that's why we took that out also let's say this is role played for a little bit if i'm um a church and i'm a small church um and i've been kind of sidelined so i'm out six of collections, let's just say.
So I do want to get some compensatory relief because I got to fix the roof on my church.
So where would I pursue damages in that case?
Say, you know, I want to, would those compensatory damages come from the state or?
That would be up to the judge.
That, I mean, we can't micromanage that yeah i mean you have every everybody has the right to file a suit and you would be able to file a suit in court and again you it says here you could uh injunctive relief you said you know six months without your collections yeah you could go before and ask for injunctive relief.
You know, you're killing my church.
I'm not getting any money.
How long is this going to last?
We need to be, we need relief here.
Or declaratory relief, compensatory, compensatory, it's been a long day.
Compensatory damages, costs, and attorney fees.
So you would have the ability to sue for all of those.
Did anybody else want to get a fine tip for Xanathonia?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I think the Senate's position is pretty clear on this.
Just one question.
The title, does that really need to be removed?
What's the title removed?
Or Was it renamed?
The title.
This act may be known and cited as the New Hampshire Religious Liberty Act.
Yeah, we just took out that whole section of the protection of religious thing.
If you're opposed to restoring the name of the bill.
No.
I'm okay with that.
So the only thing I have is the 546 scene, colon two, that those sentences just to clarify what we talked about before what the page six, just section one if we can add that language in essential government interests I support me doing that I think and I understand how C colon 2 Roman 2 of that you know might be problematic given some of the other discussions that we've had but i think and you can talk to your council that one and three actually clarify and and may be a benefit um so i don't know how long you know that.
We can.
Right there.
The room in the back, maybe we can go to the back and discuss this and okay.
Mr Chairman.
Yes, just one thing to note that that paragraph was attached to the definition.
So we'll have to take a look.
If you include the state action, the language on the state action, the state action definitions.
Do you want to speak about it?
But state action.
Because state actions.
OK.
You're the same thing.
You're taking out person.
You took out person too, right?
Yeah.
that's okay.
But you don't need those because what's in the bill is so different than common understanding of what state action.
State action applies all its subsidiaries.
That's right.
And that was a question to represent.
We'll go back and talk to Rick.
Let's see what's going on.
Gracias.
Thank you.
.
Those particular sections we had a lot of pushback on because it could have been construed as being discriminatory in that someone would be allowed to discriminate against another and use the argument that it was based on freedom of religion.
And that's why we discarded that.
And that was testimony that we had had from numerous organizations as well as the Attorney General.
So that is why we so this was so this was good.
The state action.
Yes, that's why I took for the life of me I couldn't remember why we took down the Bible person unless the person was.
Because.
Because state action would also include, let's say, the Human Rights Commission.
So if someone made a complaint to the human rights commission um they could bring action so for example if you is the thinking that say you're a catholic and obviously the catholic church doesn't ordain women so this is this kind of thing the fear was around something like that as the church is discriminating against me well it was um there were a number of issues of discrimination that had been brought up where people felt it was not very clear and so that's one reason that was the reason why we disregarded that um i the life of me, I couldn't remember why.
Because just on the face of it, you're reading it, you're like, oh, yeah, okay.
Isn't that, to me, this is just a state of religious groups in our country for a very long time.
This is the standard that all of our...
This is the intersection of the court, the legal system, and religion.
Sometimes it doesn't really make a lot of sense, unfortunately.
It can be construed in a lot of different ways, and that's why- I mean, to me, the interaction is no more right to substantially burden with religious freedom freedom.
But if someone came forward and said, well, you know, I don't particularly like so-and-so because of their lifestyle, and my religion allows me to discriminate against that person, whether it's for a job, for housing, for any other reason, that would be in direct conflict with our anti-discrimination laws.
If that could happen right now, you could just walk into court and say, if you're charged with a discrimination complaint, you could just walk into court right now and make that defense.
But we felt that again that we just really wanted to focus on the what we felt was the real emergent issue here was about the emergency protections for religion.
That's what we decided we wanted to focus on based on the testimony that we had received.
So, Representative Sylvia, you had made a recommendation which was to add in Section 1 the title.
Add Section 1 the title and section one title we're just gonna put the title back in yep so this this would go back um i think we're we're fine with that Okay.
So, well, I'll go down.
Okay.
Nothing about this was easy peasy.
I'll have you know.
This was a very I think this was one of the longest hearings that we had on this.
Yeah, no, we heard from people across the state, and that's why it was important that we came up with something that we felt that everyone could support because this was such an important issue.
We've had over 15 people sign up.
It was a lot for a Zoom meeting.
It really, really, truly was.
Anybody else had anything else in?
No, just thank you very much.
We've enjoyed working with all of you.
Well, thank you.
Thank you very much.
It was a pleasure.
And then with that, I will close the hearing on HB 542 and run down to OLX.
Okay.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
We're here for a committee of conference.
This is on House Bill 108.
My name is Ned Gordon.
I represent McFrafton House District 9 and if I could have everyone else introduce themselves around the table, that could be helpful.
I'm Representative Kurt Welker and I represent Scarborough District 3, the town of Scarborough and New Durham.
Mark Lufayne, Hillsborough District 44, which is Southern Manchester and Lynchville.
I'm Sharon Carson, and I represent Senate District 14, comprising the towns of Auburn, London, Derry, and Hudson.
Senator Gary Daniels, District 11, representing the towns of Amherst, Milford, Merrimack, and Newton.
Marjorie Smith representing Stratford 6, I think.
Durham and Acker.
They change numbers every 10 years and I never remember.
And we have a senator joining us remotely today.
Yes, good afternoon, everyone.
Senator Rebecca Perkins-Puoka.
I represent District 21, which is Portsmouth, Durham, New Market and the surrounding towns.
Can you unmute yourself?
Yeah, Senator, I think you're muted.
Yeah, you're muted.
We can't hear you.
I don't show as muted.
You may have headphones, maybe, plugged into your device, because it's's not on mute but we're not hearing you I don't have any headphones or anything plugged in can you guys hear me now I'm so glad we're done with this.
Yeah, I know.
I believe, can you hear us?
I can hear you.
Okay, we can't hear you at all.
Okay.
I know I had this problem last night.
Ah.
I was having this problem when I have to have my daughter with me.
It's like one of those generational things.
I just...
The fourth problem I got is I did that.
Oh.
And eventually fixed my tissue.
Right?
And might come unplugged or maybe it's our speaker.
And this is on.
Is there?
Sure.
Oh, excuse me.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
Yeah.
Can we call the section here?
Can I turn it off?
I turned it off on the speaker.
Are you able to hear me now?
He's left on Mars and he's trying to communicate with Earth and it's a disaster.
I have to use some obscure language.
This is only communicating with Portsmouth.
It's not quite as easy.
Hey Cam.
Would it be possible to follow the tech team?
I could our discussion we're going to.
Yes, she's like, okay.
So the house passed the house bill 108 and it had a specific provision with regard to non public sessions under the right to know law.
And the Senate added a an amendment on to that one provision.
it also added two additional provisions to the bill.
And I think probably the best way to address it or begin is to have the Senate explain what its intent was in adding those two provisions.
The last two provisions?
The last two provisions.
Okay.
The last two provisions, which was, one was Senate Bill 95.
We added it because it was something that passed, language that passed in the Senate, but unfortunately the House, ITL did, I believe.
And we felt that it had merit, so we wanted to be able to go to a committee of conference so we could have a fuller, more robust discussion between the House and the Senate.
The second provision that was passed, which is on page four, beginning on line one, number 12, records protected under the attorney client privilege of attorney attorney work product doctrine that again was an amendment that we adopted.
JoAnne Hanrahan- unanimously in the Senate in the Community and on the floor, and that is in regards to the Hampstead decision.
There was a lot of consternation across the legal community with that decision, and they felt that additional protections needed to be in place so that their work and their work product, which had traditionally been left out of 91A, was going to now continue to be exempt from 91A.
A few of the commissioners got together with the Attorney General's Office, and this was the language that the Attorney General's Office felt would have been appropriate to protect that.
And so we adopted that.
Questions from the committee?
So if the Board of Automated Manchester is meeting and they decide to go into non-public to just discuss some things with their lawyer, that would still be privileged, but it would still go on the list.
It would still be.
Yes.
Well, we felt we expanded it a little bit and made it clearer.
And again, it says for all meetings held in non-public sessions where the minutes or decisions were determined to not be subject to full public disclosure, a list of such minutes and decisions shall be kept, and this list should be made available as soon as practicable for public disclosure.
Because the testimony that we had was that oftentimes they close these public hearings.
We agree on that.
Oh, you do?
Okay.
That's the same way.
The only thing you changed in that section was we had the word promptly, and you put in the phrase, as soon as practical.
Right.
And that's just because, okay, okay, good.
I'm so prepared to explore.
I don't want to waste my time on that.
There are arguments to do here.
Yeah.
We're fine with that.
Okay.
I think the issue for me is the part two that you added, and that is with regard to continuing the remote.
remotely.
And I think the House has clearly taken a position in that regard on a couple of occasions, actually, and indicated that it did not want to continue the meetings, at least not in the manner in which they were currently being held, pursuant to the governor's executive orders.
And for some fairly obvious reasons, one of the things that is included in there is that a physical location is not even required for the meeting.
And there are many people in this state that do not have the technology to be able to participate in a meeting that doesn't have a physical location.
And we didn't feel that that was appropriate to basically disenfranchise a part of the New Hampshire population.
I believe that Senate Bill 95, as it was amended, actually addressed that because there was a requirement that there be at least a telephone.
And I was and I would be interested to hearing from the House as to why you didn't think that we should continue it.
I mean, from what I read, you wanted to study further.
And, you know, I'm looking at it, we've just had 15 months of studying it.
And, you know, from being on the on the board of select from the Milford, we've had to make adjustments.
Now and then we have the equipment that we can set up and let people join our meeting via Zoom before they watched from cable TV and they couldn't participate.
Going forward, even when we're back together, we've got the equipment.
We know that participation increases because we've gone from about two to three people that show up for a physical meeting to 35 to 45 on a selectman meeting and up to 150 on the school board uh at your hearing you had 102 people that supported that bill and two that opposed we went back and we tried we worked with the nhma to try to address those various various things so we made it we made it so that there was not a requirement that you had to have any kind of video type thing.
The only requirement was that if you were going to have a virtual meeting, then you had to have a telephone.
So somebody could call in via conference.
We know that not everybody had cameras and things like that, but pretty much everybody has a telephone.
they can go down in person and and sit because i mean there is a location uh that be at the board of slackman or room or something like that that uh someone would be able to go.
So if you took out the physical vocation requirements.
Could you help me work through something that I'm having trouble with?
And that is the difference between the members of a public body and the public so that I know in Durham, the numbers of participation have increased exponentially in planning board, zoning, town council, all that.
And I believe that's been replicated all across the state.
And I think that that is the best thing we can do in a democratic small society.
Is there a way, and am I missing something quite obvious, to differentiate between the location of the official meeting and where there would have to be at least a quorum present of the members on that board body and everybody else, everyone in addition to a quorum and the public.
Am I saying that, Senator, in a way that makes any sense?
I think I know what you're saying.
If you have five people in five different locations, you need one designated location where if somebody doesn't have a TV or doesn't have a phone, that they would be able to go and maybe watch what's going on, whether it's someplace that has a screen, something like that.
And it may be a select one.
If you're allowing center.
Yes.
I don't think that's where Representative Smith is going.
Okay.
She's trying to draw a distinction.
Right now, the right to know like that does says nothing about how boards allow public participation.
They just have to do it.
They can do anything they want.
They talk to how they meet.
And it says they have to be in person except in an emergency.
This bill said no.
And that's the big overthrow here.
It's not the participation, everybody agrees to that and there's nothing standing between the public and that ability to participate right now.
Question is, does the board need to have an actual meeting or is it virtual?
Do the select board, do the school board, do the planning board, do they have to actually come together to meet?
That's the only question that we have and one of the things that I said when we were executing this bill is that emergency provision was put in the law long before I got there.
I think it's a serious thing for us to contemplate.
It's just a reason why people meet in person, witness what we're doing right here.
OK.
And I think Representative Smith's point is well taken.
There's a distinction between the public participation and the active participation of the members of whatever governmental unit might use this.
And I think that's where our discussion has gone in the past.
And that is, I think I agree with everybody in terms of the public participation.
We should have as much public participation as possible.
We should continue that.
But there's nothing that precludes that from doing technology.
It's the question of whether or not you want remote participation by board members.
And that gets into issues with regard to right to know and people's ability to observe and their governmental units doing business.
And I'm speaking now as an individual and clearly without agreement in advance from my colleagues from the House, but I'm wondering if we could find a middle ground here in which we say that for those who serve on a body, there would have to be quarm present at one location.
Justice, we have one senator not here.
I mean, we could have, you know, in the planning board, the zoning board, whatever, in local government.
They'd have to be a quorum present, but not everyone would have to be..
Other members of the board could be virtual, which gives some flexibility there.
And then that there must be everything that we've done so far to be able to have the public observe, but at least there'd be a clear home base whether it's in town hall or in the library or this there's a there's a home base for each meeting not a hundred percent attendance required in person for the people who are on the body and as I think an acknowledgement of what we've learned in the last 15 months, that it can work and that we can conduct public business this way.
And then also along with that, everything that we can do to encourage not only the ability of the public to observe, but the ability of the public to participate because they can be recognized.
They can ask questions.
They can give a speech in the appropriate time in the agenda.
And that is very different from what we've had in the past where people could turn on their televisions and from one system or another observe what the public body is doing, but couldn't participate.
And I think the participation is a fair or the opportunity for participation is very, very important.
And I would hope that I could convince my House colleagues that there was a way to provide some middle ground between what the Senate has in terms of 95 and what we know the public values.
So would you be willing to go to a compromise to a requirement that at least two members of the board have to be in one location as opposed to a majority.
As opposed to a bar?
I don't think so and the thing and uh I think Representative Smith is on to something and I think that's a direction that we might want to go but I'm just not sure we can get that done in the seven minutes we have left to on our committee of conference.
Yeo, little faith.
And so my, and in fact, it was the Senate that proposed in Senate Bill 95 that there'd be a study committee.
Well, we did that actually as a compromise.
Yeah, well, I mean, after hearing from the House, if there was a study and so on and said, okay, in real life, we've lived through this, we are studying it and making changes as we go along.
But by adding the study committee on for, you know, three, four months, then you get that feedback so that coming into the next year, you have that ability to make further tweaks.
I mean, from my perspective, either we believe in local control or we don't.
I'm not really sure why we at the state level feel that we need to control the local governing boards.
No, we don't have local control in this state.
We know it.
Well, we don't.
I mean, state has to give the local community any less of things that they state, we know it.
We don't.
I mean, the state has to give the local community how to do any blessed thing that they want to do.
I would propose this, part one of the bill, which we sent over to you to begin with, and with your amendment, I think it's fine from my perspective.
The last part with regard to the attorney client privilege, making that an exemption, makes sense Thank you.
my perspective.
The last part with regard to the attorney-client privilege, making that an exemption makes sense, and I think we could probably agree to that.
The middle piece, I have to say that we killed 95 in our last session, including the study committee.
What I think we might be able to do is take out what you have here for your second piece and replace it with the study committee again to put that in place so that we could look at that and look at what Representative Smith was talking about.
I think we all on this side agreed that there is value, but we want to make sure that it's right and what venue does it work, what venue does it not work, as you mentioned, the Hillsborough County delegation is a shamble still i mean it's just too many people so we could change the hillsborough delegation we think that we think that there's value in studying it so that we we have a solid product but we really feel that if we don't have a break if we just allow what you're saying let's just keep it going then inertia is going to shape that final product as opposed to having that break so that we're looking at all the good all the bad and crafting a solid product and not allowing inertia to influence what that final product would be so i think that we would be more than welcome to look for the study.
I don't know if you guys can hear me.
Well, that was a nice cheer.
I so appreciate everything that's been said today.
And for the record, Senator Rebecca Perkins-Kuoka from District 21.
And I do appreciate the spirit in which it's being offered.
I do just want to make the additional point, just as a counterpoint to what was just said, Representative, that I think our municipalities, they have their operations set up under the current structure.
And so out of consideration for what they're doing in their ongoing operations and us supporting them and doing their job as easily as possible, there's also logic in allowing that operation to continue and let them do what they've been doing to the extent that it's convenient or in a compromise with one or two members present and study it, you know, and allow us to make those changes going into next year.
So I completely hear all your concerns.
I just wanted to also raise that additional point since I know they're discussing now how to meet in June and July, you know.
Because I believe with the expiration of the emergency orders, it's gone away.
I mean, we're basically back.
I happen to meet in person now.
I mean, I guess one question I have that has come out of this, and I don't know the answer to, if I as chair of the board said, you know, I will be down at town hall for the meeting, and I had four people call in with extenuating circumstances why they couldn't be there.
Is that allowed?
Or would I have to cancel the meeting?
Because the law allows people to be absent or come in via...
We were in the same problem with the...
we're coming up now uh the kind of delegation at hillsborough is going to be shortly we run into this problem all the time getting people physically present for a quorum and we're calling people um so it is a problem but yeah we have had to suspend meetings and reconvene for just that reason but i will say there is a difference between trying to get together 150 people versus five for a board meeting.
But doesn't that make the case, Mark and Kurt, as to why we should keep things going as they are while we study, rather than stop study and then have to start again because it's the same principle of physics and inertia you know a moving body you know keeps on moving a stop body is much harder to start again and i think if we could keep if we could consider this as an interim period where we keep things as they are while we study them and then change, but instead of stop, start, stop, start, which is what you're proposing, Mark.
And I understand that.
I mean, you're a scientist, I'm not.
I don't want to allow a short-term inconvenience, which this will be, to short circuit our long-term goals.
And we've had this problem at the county delegation and bodies all over the state have had this problem for a long time.
This is not a new problem so we're going to have we're going to have a break and will it be inconvenient yes but the goal is what is going to be our end product is it necessary is it necessary that is my question you know my my concern and i've used some people amazon so amazon comes in and it's so more convenient, but you don't understand where Amazon is ultimately going to take you and how it's going to alter the landscape.
So I would say, is it necessary?
Maybe it is, because I don't know that we fully understand where we're going to be in the future.
How do you understand or determine what isn't working if you shut it down?
You don't need to shut down public participation.
I think that's the issue is you say, well, we're going to change this and go back the the way we were if people organizations allowing public participation there's no reason.
John Lundberg, continue to allow public participation to through technology, the question is for board members should board members be present at me.
and that may be some convenience for a board member, but basically you take the job with that.
And that's the some convenience for a board member.
But basically, you take the job with that.
And that's the way it was a year and a half ago.
I mean, you had to be there.
That's why when we, because we amended Senegal's on 95 and Senator Daniels and I had some pretty good conversations and we had agreed that we would allow the meetings to continue, that we would put together the study committee and the study committee would have to issue a report in November.
So that legislation could be filed reflecting the findings of that study committee, but leave things the way that they are until June of next year.
And that way, any potential legislation would get, would work its way through the House and the Senate.
And the ability to do that the way that they're doing it right now would end, I think it was June 30th of 2022.
So that way, you're not going to get the stock from the start, you're going to get this continuance, you're going to get the study committee.
You're going to get legislation filed, go through the House and the Senate, not as an omnibus bill, as a standalone bill.
No more omnibus bills.
And then there would be some sort of disposition.
No matter what happens at the end of June of 2022, the way that it's being done now is over.
It's done.
So something is going to replace it.
Either you're going to go back to the old way of the requirement of, you know, you've got a board of five, all five members have to be there, or you're going to have some sort of a hybrid.
And what is that going to look like?
Because I really think we need to do the study.
We need to look at this and say, what did we do right?
What did we do wrong?
And I just think it's very important that we at least, at least do that.
So that was the thinking behind Senate Bill 95.
So I think we might, and I know, but I think that's what we're offering.
It's a compromise here rather than just trying to delete the second card.
Senator Nantles?
I don't know.
I'm frustrated because I think we're taking three steps back and we're doing a disservice to people.
I mean, they've gotten used to doing things over the last 14 months.
I don't know that anyone could say that it hasn't been successful.
We've seen that with participation.
We've seen it with the board members.
And my board, there's at least three of us who feel we like to be down at town hall.
There are a couple others that were more concerned about the COVID stuff.
They wanted to do things via Zoom.
But I mean, I don't know why we can't allow the boards to function as they feel is the best way.
If they start getting yelled at by the local residents who want to see the board in public, or even to say that, let this go until the next meeting, and then have the local public decide whether they want the board to continue with the old way or do things the new way.
I mean, so, I mean, there's another compromise there.
It's just let this go to the next annual meetings in March and let the public decide how they want.
We need to wrap up.
We do agree to what we do.
Thank you.
Oh, they won't.
We need to wrap up.
Mr.
Chair, could you clarify exactly what your proposal is?
It was to go with part one as amended by the Senate.
Part two, which was continuing meetings as they are currently held under the executive orders that be replaced with the study committee, which was in 95.
And part, and that's part two and part three, I think it is.
And part four, which is the right to know, we would agree with that.
Do you have that, Senator Perkins-Colpac?
I understand what's being proposed.
Yes, thank you.
And that is that with the U.A.G.s?
Yes, that's Adriana signage.
The second part four.
Yep.
And the effective dates as appropriate.
Yes.
um this study is better than nothing i'm not sure Senator Daniels has expressed all of my emotions exactly.
Okay, so it looks like we do have a relevant compromise.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I wish I could have voted with the Senate.
I don't want to.
Oh, come on.
You did fun.
Oh, oh, never.
Okay.
Thank you, Gary.
Senator.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Senator.
Good to see you.
I thought we had a good cover, otherwise I'm going to be fine.
Thank you.
I'm House Bill 566.
My name is Ned Gordon.
I work as a conferee for the House to chair the committee.
And I represent Grafton County District 9, 5s, Alexandria, Bridgewater, Bristol, Ashland, and Grafton.
And if anyone else would introduce themselves.
I'm Representative Kurt Walfer, I represent Stratford District 3, the town of Stratford and New Durham.
Mark McLean, Hillsborough District 44, which is Southern Manchester and Richmond.
Senator Sharon Carson, I represent London, I represent District 14, comprising of townships, Auburn, London, Derry, and Hudson.
I'm Senator Bill Gannon, I represent the Great District 23, it is the wine country of New Hampshire, in case you ever want to visit, I'll show you around.
Sandown, Thienville, Bremont, Kingston, East Kingston, Bratwood, Exeter.
I know I forgot someone.
I'll be in big trouble.
I'd like to promote our...
I thought it was sunny sandown.
Sunny sandown in the heart of New Hampshire wine country.
We missed a part.
His colleague stepped in for it.
And I live on Phillips Pond, named after King Phillips, the famous Indian king, from sandown.
That's tough to follow.
Thank you everyone.
And I think everybody has a comparison between the two versions of the bill.
The bill passed by the House, which dealt specifically with no issues and what was eventually passed by the Senate.
I note that part one of the bill is identical.
Both parties made agreements in regard to that.
Part two of the bill seems to have been deleted by the Senate.
And then there were a number of parts that were added, which constitute what was sent until 143.
And Mr.
Chairman, we're going to recede from that position.
Although Senator Whitley brought up something that we neglected to talk about this morning.
There was a request from the Department of Corrections Municipal Association.
Was it the Municipal Association?
I thought it was from the Department of Corrections.
Well, what was the department of corrections?
Municipal Association.
Was it the Municipal Association?
I thought it was from the department of corrections.
What was the request?
There was some language that they had requested to eliminate any unintended consequences.
I can either read the email or read the language that Johnson said.
I thought because I got that same email from Miss Burns, and I thought that we had taken care of that in an amendment in the in our discussions.
So that's why I didn't bring it forward.
Oh, I'm pretty sure we took care of that as you suggested, or as Margaret suggested that one.
to get that music yet.
Could you point that clarification out because i left my um senate bill 143 downstairs just exactly where it is Oh, we didn't even deal with the cybersecurity.
We understood why they took it out, so we didn't do anything with it.
We left it out.
So because it was left out there was no reason to bring that language forward.
So we're good.
So we've done right.
So well how about so part two it appears that you may have deleted part two.
Part two we deleted because we focused on House Bill 108 and 108 covers that section.
And that's why we said we need to get 156 with just the first part of that.
And it will work together with House Bill 108.
So in acceding to the position, you're acceding to just paragraph part one of the bill.
Yeah, we're just not part two.
Right.
Everything else is gone.
Oh, so.
Many members.
to the discussion on public session in the 10th subparagraph to show the data available to the public and send us a practical yeah and after the transaction Yeah.
And That's where we got the language that we sent to you is in one way now.
Yes.
Okay.
So that's right.
That was literally.
Yep.
That was the language.
Except for that.
So, so, no one.
That's right.
We already discussed that one.
Yeah, there it is right there.
Yeah.
We still have our one away from them.
So, that's right.
I just compared it work for word.
And the only difference was we had, that's interesting, because this one we had immediately.
As soon as talking about that.
Yeah.
Okay.
We have an agreement, everybody?
Yep.
Yes.
Sounds good.
Great.
Thank you.
You've got to know the word.
I didn't know about that.
So, oh, Mr.
Chairman, 143 is ready for sign-off.
Okay.
Thank you.
So, oh, Mr.
Chairman, 143 is ready for sign off.
Okay.
Take care of that right now.
I'll go with you.
Okay.
Thank you.